just meters from the port this was the
neighborhood
which felt much of the ferocious force
of the explosion
not a window not a door not a building
is untouched round here
the country's main silo of grain is now
exposed
it's still smoldering where the huge
store of highly reactive ammonium
nitrate was kept
helicopter teams have spent much of the
past 24 hours trying to bring the fires
under control
there is still a chance of finding
people buried beneath the rubble
beirut is literally holding its breath
right now
the city which thought it was
unshockable is reeling from this
so many have been left with nothing
here is my home my house there are
hundreds of
thousands like alan ciao in beirut now
and then one second
we lose everything what we do all life
with all cars everything
look at the state of this house
oh my goodness families all over the
city
facing destitution with homes
unrecognizable
and uninhabitable
oh my goodness look his father was
sleeping here and he obviously got
terribly injured blood stains on the
door
is he all right now
very badly hurt no not very he's lucky
very very lucky very lucky
this is a people a city in shock how
worried are you about the future
there is no real future anymore in
lebanon if there is a boat now
we will take the boat and leave lebanon
leave alone you cannot stay
the hospitals are packed with thousands
of injured many of the medics haven't
slept since the explosion
there are just too many to treat we were
given special access to one of the
city's
biggest hospitals the medical director
described the scenes here
as apocalyptic many hurt will not make
it
scare so that means people who are
seriously seriously
from 500 injured so nearly half was
seriously hurt
[Music]
just four days old and sophie is
fighting for her life
she suffered bleeding on her brain after
being showered with glass whilst
breastfeeding
the doctors have yet to decide whether
to operate
her distraught new parents are waiting
outside
and they won't leave without her in a
couple of seconds
and a couple of seconds we we turned 180
degrees
we had our home our family our new baby
girl
now we haven't been very happy with her
and we are waiting for her now
the explosion uh
explored everything in the house
everywhere look at me i tried to protect
her
but i couldn't do more than this
life for so many here will never be the
same
alex crawford sky news beirut